a visionary not for the last three weeks
doubts in westminster tension over big
decisions
massive spending on transport for the
north 96 billion pounds nothing like it
again nothing like it overshadowed by
broken promises
were the voters of the north right to
take the prime minister at his word
a long-term policy failure they promised
to fix unresolved meaning human tragedy
in the channel
this disaster
underscores how dangerous it is to cross
the channel anger that the least well
off got a worse deal on social care it's
another broken promise and concern as to
whether the prime minister was quite at
the top of his game this week in a major
speech
i've anybody's been to pep a big world
not enough
leading to uncomfortable questioning
is everything okay prime minister
to test that important question does any
of this make a difference in the country
we asked voters in the south london seat
of old bexley and syd cup where there is
a by-election next week i've always
voted tori i always voted to tour it and
events of the last few days yes they've
made me wobbly a little bit and why is
that
i just don't trust boris i just don't
think the man's got a grip what do you
think of the last two weeks
not very good why
why um
i don't think he's giving people
confidence at the moment
because there's a lot with immigration
there's a lot lots of things he's done
very good
but all of a sudden i think he's gone
off the boil have you voted for him in
the past i have and what's
started to change your mind about what
you think of him um well he's fumbling
around a lot i think
i'm talking about peppa pig do you think
what you've seen even in the last few
weeks is going to change the way you
vote next week
probably not
it's not that the voters around here
don't know about the sleaze scandals the
migrant boat crisis or the stumbles in
the prime minister's speech
unlike some politicians however they
take a longer view
mps can wobble voters
seem to hold their nerve holding their
nerve because voters point to and care
about the assistance government gave to
individuals and small businesses over
the last two years of the pandemic is
there's anything he could do that would
mean he probably didn't get your vote
next time
oh god
um
probably not no
in westminster northern mps like andrew
percy who voted against his government
this week worry about its direction
there are too many issues at the moment
in which the government is shooting
itself in the full with with with issues
and problems which as i say colleagues
are warning warning and warning about
and that are visible from venus mars
even maybe even visible from pluto and
that has got to stop because we owe the
people of this country better than that
many mps are concerned boris johnson
promised big but is struggling to
deliver and this also applies to boats
crossing the channel there's a genuine
concern that the government has talked
tough quite rightly the government
genuinely wants this trade to end as we
all uh do
but we haven't been able to achieve that
on our own because most of the cards are
in the hands of the french and perhaps
it was unwise to over promise
when we couldn't rely on the sort of
partnership that we need a by-election
here next week and another in two weeks
that will tell us whether the country
shares the concerns of boris johnson's
mps
sam coates sky news